[Music]
drex here from drexfactory.com sharing
with you the love of poi spinning and
flow earth to benefit your body and
brain and today i have a long awaited
beginner combo tutorial for you all
before we dive in though i just want to
give a quick shout out to the friends of
the channel big thanks to dark monk fire
mecca flow fests flow toys juggling
calling pyroterra light toys spin balls
and ultra poi for helping to make the
videos on this channel possible you can
learn more about all these amazing
businesses and what they're doing to
support flow artists like yourself by
checking out the links that i've got
down in the description of this video
and special thanks to non-business
friends of the channel johnny howard les
muchinski and becca beckham thank you
all so very much for your support from
my work and my mission
so many of us poi spinners learn our
tricks in isolation and have no idea how
to switch back and forth between them so
every once in a while i try and come up
with a cool way that you can combine
what you've got and also give yourself
some additional learning that'll help
you with your poi dance in the future
that's the purpose of these combo
tutorials and this particular one is a
beginner combo that centers around both
level changes as well as plane changes
if you're new here please make sure to
hit that subscribe button i post lots of
videos on learning poi tricks and
technique and combos such as this as
well as flow arts culture to get down
this combo you're gonna need the
following poi tricks number one the
forwards three beat weave
number two the windmill and specifically
the variation of it sometimes called poi
truvian man
horizontal flowers
and of course stalls
i will go ahead and leave links to
tutorials for all of these different
tricks down in the description as well
as up in the cards if you are watching
this video on youtube i'll show you the
combo first at full speed take you
through it piece by piece and then show
it to you again in slow motion
[Music]
me
all right so basically there's two
primary reasons that i'm putting
together this combo the first is that as
you may have noticed it involves a lot
of level changes that is going high with
the poi and going low with the poi as
well as getting comfortable with
stalling out of split time same
direction a lot of beginners really
wrestle with this so i wanted to create
a combo that was specifically geared
towards this
now
this
starts out by taking
really like this moves back and forth so
if you want to you can start a little
off to stage left here
what you're going to be doing throughout
most of this combo is doing steps out
to one side and then steps out to the
other side so it kind of moves back and
forth uh the basic step that you're
going to be playing with is whichever
direction you're moving you're going to
cross the opposite foot over so if i'm
moving to the right i'm crossing my left
in front of my right
and then i'm opening up as i go back to
the left i'm going to cross my right
over my left
and open back up there is one exception
to this and it's when we're doing these
horizontal flowers in which case we're
doing a sun a step
so what that involves is basically i
swing my
left foot around in front of me and my
right foot around behind me we do the
shun i step back to the left side as
well by swinging the right foot in front
of us and swinging the left foot behind
us that is should be all the footwork
you need for this all right so let's
talk about what the poi is doing here um
i very deliberately did this in such a
way that there would never be a time
when the poi felt like it was going
reverse split time same direction only
forwards so we go ahead and we start off
by turning to our right and doing a
forwards three beat weave in that
direction now you're only going to get
in one rep of this what that means is
that you're going to go left over right
right over left and then you're going to
stall out of it you're going to kind of
open up in front of you
and then you're going to switch into
doing a forwards weave off to your left
side with the right going over the left
the left going over the right and
stalling out of it like so
this combines with the footwork as such
as my left hand goes over my right hand
my left foot crosses in front
and we open up so there's actually a
reflection in what the feet are doing
with what the poi are doing again
left over right
and then back open
right over left
and then back open it kind of it kind of
rhymes with itself george lucas style
you see again it's like poetry so if
they rhyme
every stanza kind of rhymes with the
last one all right so after we do our
step off to the
right
open
left
open we switch things up and out of our
three beat weaves and instead go into
our windmills now it's going to be
interesting because it's going to
involve a level change instead of
keeping the poi at about shoulder or
maybe hip height we're now taking it up
above our shoulders i also want to add a
new element to this in that when we do
the thing where we go over to the side
here we stall our poi down and we kind
of drop down in our levels with it yeah
so the windmill is going to start from
this place where i believe i have my
right poi up my left poi down because i
just came from stalling this weave here
boom and as that happens my first move
is to pull that left hand poi up around
behind my left shoulder like so as that
happens my left foot steps in front and
i step back out in order to stall now my
left hand poi is up my right hand poi is
down and as i go back to the other side
i'm going to go
right behind and out but remember we
want to do this from a place where we go
down so it turns into
go around and down
go around
and down you're trying to get down in
your levels on each side there around
and down
around
and down like so so the final little
section of this is going to involve
doing horizontal flowers back and forth
across the stage
and there's there's going to be kind of
a trick to this because the first time
around we're going to do those
horizontal flowers under our arms and
the second time around we're going to do
them over our arms just to get used to
each of these right
so for this case we're going to bring
our poi around
as we step out with our left foot
and then our right foot so you're going
to do like basically
one petal here
boom when you take the step and then
open back out and you're going to take
one petal as you step out
and come around really you can more or
less pull this off just by like letting
the poi hang out to the side and pausing
for a second when you take that step
this this almost happens just naturally
by itself if you just leave your arms
out and let the poi do what they're
gonna do it does get a little bit more
complicated though when we do the second
half of the horizontal flowers namely
we now have to take them above our
shoulders which means that we have to
put a little bit more energy into them
i kind of think of this as like i'm kind
of flinging the poi up and around
and um i don't know if you can ch if
this reads very much but i also feel
like i do a little bit of a head check
up boom as the poi are going over my
shoulders to kind of make sure that i'm
giving my a little bit of attention from
my chin as the poi are going up there
too yeah all right so the full combo is
as such we go ahead and do left over
right
open
right over left
open windmill around to down
windmill around to down
horizontal flowers underneath horizontal
flowers underneath horizontal flowers up
above
and horizontal flowers up above and if
you want to finish it off with one last
stall to bring the poi together
cool let's have another look at that in
slo-mo
[Music]
so
do
cool i hope this gets some of you all
out there more comfortable both with
your level changes as well as with
stalling at a split time same direction
we've covered a lot of ways to do that
uh before you go please do me a favor
and if you post video of yourself doing
this combo make sure to tag me i am
drexfactor on both instagram and youtube
and i would love to see your hard work
[Music]
if you got anything out of this video
please make sure to like comment share
and subscribe to help other people find
it and of course to help my channel grow
this video would not be possible were it
not for the awesome support of all of
these wonderful people right here these
are my flow patrons over on patreon and
they along with the people listed down
in the description helped to make this
video and all the videos on this channel
possible thank you one and all for your
support if you out there watching are
not currently a supporter and would like
to become one you can do so by heading
on over to patreon.com drexfactorpoi and
signing up there you will get access to
a whole host of awesome rewards and be
helping me out in my mission to bring
poi spinning and flow arts to the wider
world so go check that out please and
thank you if you dug this video and
you're hungry for more of my combo
tutorials i will go ahead and leave a
link to a playlist of them down in the
description as well as up on screen if
you are watching on youtube also the
youtube algorithm thinks that you're
really going to like this top video here
so you might want to give that a look
too
thank you all so much for watching make
sure to get out and flow and i will see
you with a brand new video on monday
please take care and i'll see you soon
peace